Fascinated me with your Twitter page and you like,
first of all, how you are a doctor, right?
Well, I'm a PhD. I can't save anybody's life. I could perform, you know,
Victorian surgery, amputation or something, but anybody can, right? Yeah,
no, this is, this is a prop. Um, so this is, this was a,
it was a real fun thing to get through customs when I was coming in from
Britain. It's a Victorian amputation saw. It's called the clockwork saw.
And um, for people who are just listening, it's,
it's a circular saw and there would have been a crank that you wound it with and
then you'd release it and it would spin sort of automatically. Oh yeah.
And the idea was that it would make it faster.
But the reason why I love this sauce so much is that it was a massive failure.
And, um, I don't think we talk about failure enough in science and medicine.
You know, all the things that work, there's a lot of things that don't work.
And so this guy who invented this saw, when he tried it out,
it was spinning so fast that he took off his assistance fingers. Oh,
Jesus Christ, oops. It never got out of prototype phase.
So I had to recreate it for my YouTube channel.
Now when you were in those old days when they didn't have antibiotics and
antiseptic, and when they saw someone's leg off or something like that,
how many times those people live?
Well, you could pull through the operation. That was one part of it.
But then of course you could die a postoperative infection. So my book,
the Patreon art really focuses on this one guy named Joseph Lister,
who applies germ theory and develops antisepsis. So germ fighting techniques,
and most people don't know who he is, but they know the product. Listerine.
So Listerine was named after him by, uh,
I always tell people that. So basically, uh,
Lister was a British surgeon and he came to America in 1876 to convince the
medical community of germs.
And there was a guy in the audience and he decided to create this product.
Listerine. But it wasn't even a mouthwash in the 19th century.
It was used to treat gonorrhea. Whoa. So,
but also I don't endorse that little Listerine.
I could just see all the comments already on the YouTube, you know,
she told me to throw a story and I didn't know I, I don't endorse that.
And I'm sure the Listerine company is not too pleased I talking about that
either. So Listerine now just is for breath, right? Yeah,
yeah. It's, yeah, it's, it's a, it's an antiseptic mouthwash and so
good for you. Like is it good to kill all that stuff inside your mouth? Like
I'm not a real doctor or a medical historian. I'm a medical historian.
I would say that Dennis would say that that was strings still a good product.
[inaudible] bacteria. Yeah, form of it. Something like that.
I just use something, I don't know if it's cropped mouthwash.
You got to switch to Listerine now in honor of, of Joseph Lister.
So how did he know? How did he know that there was germs? That they were real?
So let me, let me take you back to sort of before he walks on the scene.
So these operating theaters, they were filled to the rafters,
ticketed spectators,
people actually bought tickets to see someone get their leg hacked off. Oh God,
no, I, you know what, no one's asked me that.
I don't know how much the ticket would cost for that. That's spectacle.
Now I really need to look into that.
But people would pay to watch that they paid for the book,
what they pay to watch now. Right. You know, we could say, you know,
and when I sent you my book, I signed it and I said,
I thought that being strapped to the Victorian operating theater was the
original fear factor because I can't imagine anything worse than being strapped
to this table. And so we're talking about before anesthesia.
So you're fully awake.
And one of my favorite surgeons is this guy named Robert list and he's six two,
he's really tall for the 19th century.
And he could hold you down with his left arm and you could take your leg off in
about 30 seconds. Oh Jesus. Which is what you'd want. That's what you'd want.
But that's still a long time. It is. Yeah.
I mean if we just sat here for 30 seconds with dead air time and you could think
about hacking through that leg and
I wonder how many people would be at the end of this podcast.
Like five people would be still out there listening. Um, so,
so he was incredibly fast. He was known as the fastest knife in the West end.
He would walk in, he was a showman. So he'd walk in and he'd say,
tie me gentlemen and you could just hear the ripple of pocket watches as they
came out there is, yup.
There he is in that photo. Yeah.
So actually the list and knife that he invented was this long bladed knife,
which they think Jack the ripper may have also used,
which is why those rumors are that Jack the ripper may have been a medical
practitioner, but a really common thought.
Yeah. I mean we're never going to know who he is. It's unknowable.
We're still kind of obsessed with this.
I've heard so many different versions that, yeah.
And recently there was some kind of bogus DNA test of,
of a shawl that they said belonged to one of the victims,
but it's impossible to prove the Providence of the object, but that was listed.
So he's six two, he's really tall.
One of my favorite stories is he would go so fast as he was switching
instruments,
he'd hold these bloody instruments in his mouth just to illustrate how different
this was. That's the face I wanted.
I wanted to just be just totally disgusted through this whole segment. Um,
and as he was switching instruments,
he accidentally cut off his assistance finger and then as he was switching
instrument,
he slashed the code of the spectator and the assistant died of gangrene.
The patient died of gangrene and the spectator died of fright. So it's juggling.
He died of the red blood. Well he got slashed in the,
with the jacket and I guess he had a heart attack from the stress.
And so it's jokingly referred to as the only operation with a 300% mortality
rate. You did a good job that day. He killed three, three people in one.
And you say slashed, you mean he cut the spectator or just, no,
he just cut their coat as he was kind of switching instruments to kill someone.
I thought people were tougher back then. Well, not that guy.
And now he lives forever in the butchery and art is that guy.
I had a heart attack. He must've had a heart attack.
It said he died a afraid maybe that wasn't real. Maybe it wasn't a core shit,
doesn't it? A little bit like no, you, no, no, no, no, no.
Of course these stories, you know, they get, they get blown out or proportion.
Yeah. Just seems like, did you cut someone's jacket, let die? Well,
it's, you know, it's a stressful situation.
People are getting their limbs hacked off, you know,
your blood pressure would be really high. Um, and the, in these theaters were,
I mean the, the floor of the operating theater was crowded as well,
so they'd have to actually clear the floor sometimes. So you can imagine,
you know, you're strapped to this and the leg wasn't the worst thing.
So one of the tweets that you shared of mine, which, uh,
your platforms seem to enjoy quite a lot and sold me a lot of books by the way.
Thank you. Um,
well it's this story about this guy who was suffering from a bladder stone and
it got stuck in his urethra.
And so out of desperation he stuck a nail down his penis and he hammered it to
break it up. I remember that. And uh, yeah,
people went nuts on your platform for that story. So they,
they obviously are ready for this interview. How did that work again?
It didn't work right? It did not work. Now he died. Oops.
That guy definitely died. Um, but it's,
it really illustrates how desperate people were back then and how few options
they had. There's the image of it.
I don't think you'll have to show this on YouTube, Jamie.
That was the one I said.
I'm sure it's a medical image on YouTube. Really. It's clearly a penis.
There's, there's penises and breasts on YouTube. Penis photos.
Think they look at us more carefully. All right, well it's not on there.
I'm just, okay, good. I'll tweet it later for people.
You have people want to see it. We'll tweet.
Twitter is the most open of all platforms.
I'll let you get away with almost everything. You can have porn on Twitter.
Yeah. Well, I mean, I don't have any problems with Instagram.
I put that stuff up, but, but maybe again, things get removed some Instagram.
It's really kind of interesting.
It seems to be dependent upon how many people complain. Yeah,
probably there's, there's always those people out there looking to be offended.
I just think they just want to do something.
They just want to press that button. Yeah. There we go. I know I get a L,
you know, at this point there's so many objects that that can cause a fence,
of course, with medical history and it's, it's, you know,
there's a lot of dark history Bodysnatchers and things like that.
And I'm a firm believer that we should tell these stories openly because they
happened in medicine and science grew as a result of it. But,
but they're not easy subjects to discuss with an audience,
especially when you have so many characters on Twitter and you're,
you're trying to get out a complex idea, but also like you're not just, ER,
there's a lot of Twitter pages that I follow where people just try to gross
people out. You're actually educating people the history
and we all should be really thankful that these people went through all this
stuff so that we don't have to.
Yeah, absolutely. I always say to my audience, so I,
I'd been going around the world sort of demolishing romantic notions about
people who might think about what it's like to live in the past.
Cause it was pretty, pretty bad.
And I have visuals as well and I've had four men faints so far.
It's always been, man, it's just a commentary right now. It's always been men.
Yeah, it was that guy. Yeah, those, those weaklings coming to my lecture.
And I think what it is though is people think I'm going to see something gross
so I'm not going to eat. And then their blood sugar plummets.
So it's not really the crisis, but they're not really prepared, you know,
and they're, yeah. And they're standing.
Sometimes I give lectures at this incredible museum called the old operating
theater in London. It's the second oldest in the world.
And so you have to stand because it's like a Victorian operating theater and so
people lock their knees or whatever.
Oh wow. So you give actual lectures in the real theaters where they used to cut.
Yeah. Yeah. I did my book launch there and if people want to see it, um,
I filmed sort of a,
like a theatrical scene of a young Lister attending an operation in that theater
and it's on my YouTube channel condo under the knife. Um,
and I really want to get this made into a movie. Um,
I'm trying to come into Hollywood and convince Hollywood that this Quaker
certain from the Victorian period deserves the cinema a feature,
but it is an Epic story. He saved more lives than any other person to ever live.
Well, look at it is an Epic story.
And for anybody who's ever gone through operations,
and I've gone through several of them, we owe those people a massive,
yeah, you don't have to be awake strapped to the table.
Both my knees reconstructed. Yeah. Wake up and they're fixed. Yeah,
it's amazing. And in the past, before anesthesia,
a lot of times patients were sat in chairs so they weren't laid down. Um,
and they were sat in these very high chairs so that their feet dangled so they
couldn't brace against the knife.
If you think about pushing off with your right, um, there's a,
there's a story about a guy named Robert Penman and I know we have images and
I'm sure YouTube won't take those down. Um, he, he comes to, uh,
Robert Liston,
the fastest knife in the West end in the eight and 1828 and he has this huge
facial tumor growing. I mean, it's been growing for about eight years.
It's taking off his whole face.
He can't breathe now and list and looks at him and says,
I can't do this operation, which is tantamount to a death sentence.
But he goes up to Scotland and he goes, there he is. Wow. Yeah, it's,
it's incredible when you see that painting. Um,
so Penman goes up to Scotland and he sees a guy named James Simon Sime agrees to
do this operation and payment is sat for 24 minutes in a chair restrained while
this thing is caught out of his face, drops in a bucket. And, and um,
yeah. Well we have a picture of him later in life, you know, and he,
yeah,
it looks kind of like an ugly Abraham Lincoln and Lincoln wasn't really known
for his looks. He doesn't have a thing on his face though. Yeah. I mean,
you could see that the jaw is definitely slimmer,
but he doesn't look too deformed considering what he went through.
So it is incredible. Um, you get such crazy stories,
like there's a woman who has a mastectomy in 1840 without any anesthetic.
Now at this time, you would have, if you were wealthy or if you're middle-class,
you'd have this operation in your home.
You just have it on like your kitchen table, which is,
which would have been safer than going into the hospitals. Yeah.
Because the hospitals were crawling with all kinds of infection.
So hospitals were places for the poor.
And to give you an idea of how gross it was,
the bug catcher who had read on the beds of lice,
he was paid more than the doctors and surgeons in this time. Yeah.
Cause I mean that's pretty important, right? There's maggots,
all kinds of things crawling around in these hospitals.
So if you are wealthy or middle class,
you had your surgeon come to your home and so she has a surgeon come and the
surgeon determines that yes, the bras has to come off and says,
I'm going to return, but I'm not going to tell you the day,
which would make me more anxious.
He thought it was going to help her not focus on it,
but all you would be thinking about right is when is this guy going to show up?
That's a person without breasts. Yeah, yeah, exactly. He was like,
I'll just show up. It'll be easy.
And so he shows up and he goes into her bedroom and he opens his hand and shows
of the knife he's gonna use and he says to prepare her soul for death.
Like this isn't very confidence inspiring.
Any doctors listening don't tell your patients to prepare their soul for debt.
And um, and she's,
she does survive and she talks about how it's so vascular that the blood blinds
him at one point. And so like, just when you think it can't get worse,
he can't see and he's under,
she is under his hand for an hour and a half cups away and she survived. She,
she ends up living a long and somewhat happy life.
I'm sure she had a lot of nightmares. Yeah,
there was see us or do they tie this woman down? Like how do they, Oh yeah,
they would've definitely had to restrain her. I mean,
I mean people were probably a little bit stronger or more able to adapt to pain
than we are. But nonetheless, there would have been some pretty heavy restraint.
That was in the 1840s.
So we know when cancer became common or was it always common?
Humans? That's a good question.
The oldest archeological record I believe is 2000 years old of metastatic
cancers. So it's older than you think.
They're diagnosing it for for centuries and centuries.
I'm not really an expert in history of cancer, but it is around.
And so with breast cancer, you know,
probably by the time it got to the stage of mastectomy,
it probably would've spread.
If you think about like you know it being visible to the naked eye yet she
survived. She did survive.
And so then you have to question whether she had breast cancer or maybe it was
some kind of like, yeah, maybe a, and she went through that for that. But yeah,
and again,
before antiseptics before Lister comes on and comes up with germ fighting
techniques,
this would have been so dangerous because you have this open cavity and wounds.
And so Joseph Lister, when he comes up with his antiseptic techniques,
he actually performs a mastectomy on his sister, on his dining room table,
which, and she survives. And that's in the book. See this,
this would be a great movie. Don't you think?
I do think it would be a great movie. It's like,
it would be a great movie for the Cohen brothers. Yeah. Yeah.
Cause it's so chaos Phil. I know. And all of that kind of grittiness and yeah.
Good period pieces too. Yeah. They could make it more entertaining.
Make this happen. Joe. I'm not a part of that world.
This guy with the face where they cut that tumor out of his face.
So for 24 minutes,
that's all it took to cut that thing out of his face and that, that case. Yeah.
And remember of course it depended on the skill of your surgeon.
So he goes to a very good surgeon named James Syme. Um, but there,
there a story. So going back to penises, um,
there's lithotomy is the removal of the stone,
which you saw kind of a demonstration there. Um, and it was incredibly painful.
So they stuck a rod on the penis and they cut through the scrotum.
They removed the stone.
And of course there was no pain medication and it was just awful.
Did they drink it? You know, it's kind of a myth because of course,
drinking within your blood, but someone asked me, they said,
I heard that surgeons would punch the patient out, and I was like, Oh,
you have to be really good to knock someone out on a first punch.
And of course he'd do more damage. You could do a lot of damage to the hat.
That's definitely didn't happen.